muy bien hoy vamos a echar un vistazo a
esta secadora de cabello vamos a ver los
diferentes sistemas y funciones dentro
de ella cómo fue hecha y cómo funciona
además quiero ver cómo podemos producir
una secadora de cabello por menos de
ocho dólares y aún así generar ganancias
para poder seguir en el negocio como
compañía ya que bueno esta tiene un
precio muy bajo y la manera en la que se
hace es reducir un montón los costos en
complejidad y veremos cómo lo hacen así
que lo primero que quiero que veamos es
el conector este es un conector con
interruptor de circuito de fallo a
tierra y bueno lo primero que quiero que
observes es que tiene dos diferentes
medidas en la clavija una clavija más
ancha y otra más corta y esto es muy
importante porque quiero que sepas que
la clavija ancha es la clavija neutra y
eso significa que no puedes conectar
este enchufe de manera incorrecta estás
debe ir en un solo sentido y eso
significa que la energía está aterrizada
adecuadamente y la energía siempre va
hacia tierra
es un punto crítico en un circuito como
este lo que hace este enchufe es algo
realmente inteligente ya que puede
decirnos si hay una diferencia de
energía entre ambas clavijas esa
diferencia de energía puede ocurrir
cuando la secadora sea arrojada al agua
o existe un cortocircuito dentro de la
secadora se abren contactos eléctricos
que si se ponen dentro del agua o algún
líquido conductivo tendrán un
cortocircuito y lo que sucederá es que
se electrificará el fluido ahora bien en
el pasado eso era un problema ya que la
gente se electrocutaban y ahora no es
gran cosa porque tenemos este conector
con interruptor de circuito de fallo a
tierra así que qué te parece si vemos
que hay adentro de este conector ya
había quitado el soporte desde este
ángulo y pérez y puedo quitar el resto
quiero mencionar algo rápido desde un
punto de vista de seguridad es
absolutamente importante que jamás
retiren un conector sin ayuda de un
profesional y si tienen ayudado el
profesional y van a retirar un conector
ourense de que no volverán a conectarlo
ahora bien observa que esta cubierta es
de plástico moldeado y fue moldeado por
inyección es decir hay dos piezas de
acero que se juntan y el plástico
derretido es inyectado adentro de ellas
de hecho pueden observar que aquí hay
marcas de pernos y esto es porque los
pernos entran dentro del molde y empuja
en el plástico hacia afuera y por aquí
hay una pequeña pieza de plástico con un
resorte y eso es para el interruptor de
prueba el interruptor de prueba
presionan esto de aquí en la placa de
circuito impreso y el interruptor de
reinicio está justo aquí si lo presionas
se reiniciarán y si lo acciona puedes
volver a usar la secadora otra vez más
tarde ahora pasemos a ver aquí la placa
de circuito impreso porque aquí tenemos
un montón de cosas interesantes primero
quiero que observes que está hecha de
fibra de vidrio de una capa muy delgada
de cobre aplicada a ella y el cobre es
recubierto por una capa de
y antes de que coloque en la capa de la
campo quita en la parte del cobre es por
eso que hay espacios en donde no hay
cobre y espacios donde sirve y estos
espacios donde no hay cobre son llamados
pistas y éstas funcionan como pequeños
cables estas pistas son muy planas y
compactas y te permiten colocar
bastantes cosas en un espacio reducido y
por esta razón es por la cual usamos una
placa de circuito impreso ahora por aquí
pueden ver que tenemos un pequeño
capacitor es un capacitor de montaje
superficial y también tenemos una
pequeña resistencia recuerden que el
capacitor almacenen una carga y después
la libera mientras que la resistencia
resistirá el flujo de corriente así que
esto mismo puede ser usado para proteger
diferentes partes del circuito y esta
parte de aquí es llamada circuito
integrado y lo que hace es recibir
órdenes de las cosas que hay en la parte
posterior es decir recibe información de
todas esas cosas y decide qué hacer con
ella y esto de aquí se llama un anillo
toroidal o un embobinado de cobre
y básicamente lo que hacen es consentir
la diferencia entre estas dos líneas
entonces cuando hay una diferencia
significativa de voltaje inclusive
pueden ser unos pocos milián pérez envía
esa información al circuito integrado y
el circuito integrado le dice a esto a
esta kim que es un self en hoy de de
hecho es un shell en all the lineal a él
le envía la electricidad y provoca que
este pivote se dispare y cuando el
pivote se dispara rompe la conexión del
circuito y no hay posibilidad de que
pueda recibir una descarga también por
acá podemos ver un par de partes
interesantes en esta placa esta de aquí
es un capacitor electrolítico y también
tenemos otro capacitador justo aquí aquí
lo pueden ver es un capacitor cerámico
de color tipo óxido y si quito esto por
aquí
'no podrán ver mejor ahora este de acá
es un tránsito él puede funcionar con un
interruptor en un circuito y este es un
bar y storm o una resistencia variable y
éste puede proteger el circuito de
voltajes altos y cosas similares
el barí store es una resistencia no
lineal o en otras palabras cambia según
el flujo de corriente que recibe es una
resistencia que cambia y puede proteger
el circuito y por acá en el interior
pueden ver el lado posterior de las
clavijas y si te das cuenta son solo
piezas de latón con cables que van
soldados en la placa y aquí está la
parte de la cubierta del interruptor o
mejor dicho del conector la cual está
hecha de plástico moldeado por inyección
y después tenemos este cable que sale
justo aquí este tiene una pieza
protectora de goma que sirve para que el
cable pueda moverse hacia atrás y hacia
adelante dentro de la cubierta sin
desgastarse ahora si ven justo aquí hay
una advertencia que dice desconecte lo
no retire esta etiqueta y eso quiere
decir que después de todo todavía
quieren advertirnos que definitivamente
no es seguro arrojar la secadora de
cabello al agua esta es una precaución
de seguridad pero no es una buena idea
poner una secadora en el agua porque es
un aparato eléctrico que tiene contactos
abiertos en su interior